i was watching cnn this morning for a
few minutes and they were showing
somebody threw out a horrendous first
pitch i forget the name of the steve
aoki
yeah
and i was watching and they go wow that
was the worst pitch and they and then
the woman goes ah
i got to tell you been a lot of bad
pitches and i thought gary's name was
going to come up but she spared them she
didn't uh
maybe gary's dropping down on the list
because it's come up in plenty of other
places believe me i'm just looking on
social media this morning apparently
according to most people i've dropped to
number three it's steve aoki 50 cent and
then me
but but it's only been 13 years
since why anybody would uh ever throw
out the first pitch is beyond me unless
you're a
very accomplished uh player i don't see
what the upside is in it and i i told
gary that i said gary oh it's my dream
balls
yeah i don't know why that was a dream
and the next thing i know a nervous ball
from with the hypnotist
i mean what are you doing he's got a
coach he took lessons
well think about it let's say gary threw
out a wonderful first pitch you know
okay got it over the plate
big [ __ ] deal nobody would have
talked about it again nobody that's
right nobody gives a [ __ ] nobody cares
but gary's a dreamer
stop with the dream what he was doing
that day he fell asleep in the office he
was having one of his dreams that's what
i said i said you're lucky i don't fire
you i told you you dreamed too much
gary
oh boy i'm gonna throw the person
that's a childhood fantasy to be in shea
stadium both it's somebody who had
dreamed it all i couldn't believe it
could go that wrong
i've seen you throw the ball and you do
fine and that was like maybe the second
ball i ever threw
i love gary i felt bad for him but he is
stubborn
he never listens to me you know both you
think you know everything just because
you're the both
i really don't know everything but i
know everything about gary and i
i predict a disaster
gary's [ __ ]
gary's pitch
gary through like a little [ __ ]
it's been a while but we still smile
when gary misses the plate by a mile
baba boo he wanted the pitch to go well
he said it looked as bad as he smelled
so this season as you watch the games
don't forget about one thing
gary's pitch
gary's pitch the biggest [ __ ] up by far
oh yeah
all right listen i'm not gonna rub it